you're about $500 or $600,000 behind and
so um no I think your plan's too slow I
would get more radical if I was in your
shoes I would get a $30,000 truck I
would sell this one or or a $110,000
truck and I pay off the stuff by
Christmas I'd be debt free other than
the house uh and every dollar I can
squeeze out I'm I'm then going to start
putting 15% of my income into retirement
and everything else towards this house
and I want the house paid off in like
three
years not in seven years and then I want
you just loading up 401ks and Roth IRAs
and anything else you can load up in
good mutual funds then you will end up
with about4 $500,000 in a paid for house
at 72 the track you're on right now
you're going to end up with about
$250,000 in a paid for house at 72